So hi, my name is
Harvey Lieberman,
and I am here today to tell
you a little bit about the, R
pharma organization,
who we are, what we do,
and how you can get involved.
If you're interested.
So R is ubiquitous within
the pharmaceutical industry.
But until recently,
there hasn't really
been a group that works across
multiple pharma companies
to provide a space
for users to interact.
In 2017, a group of R users
from several pharma companies
got together with
other organizations
interested in this space,
such as the FDA and Harvard,
to form a group.
And that's how R
pharma was born.
R/Pharma is an R
Consortium ISC working group,
it's organized by a
group of volunteers
from multiple organizations and
some of the companies involved
in setting up the
R/pharma conference
are listed on this slide.
Now, the goal of
R/pharma has been
to host a scientifically
and industry oriented
conference focused
on the use of R
in the development of
pharmaceuticals. The conference
covers topics such as genomics,
drug discovery, pk, pd,
clinical trials, regulatory
compliance and validation,
as well as more general topics
such as reproducible research
and DevOps.
The focus is on the use
of R as a primary,
but not necessarily exclusive
tool in the drug development
process.
We also hold workshops
at the conference,
but since the primary focus
is for R practitioners,
the workshops are
really aimed at those
who are already
competent in R.
Anyone's welcome to
present a workshop.
And we we're lucky to have
some really amazing presenters,
as you'll see on some
of the later slides.
Now there are plenty of data
science conferences, workshops
and even organizations.
So what makes us different?
Well, for one, we're run
by pharma, for pharma.
We concentrate on
R, which is not
to say we don't have
contributing talks that include
python, Sas or even julia, but
just that R is the main focus.
The R/pharma conference that
we've held the past three years
has been free.
Any cost has been assumed
by an advisory group, which
is generally made up of pharma
companies willing to support
the cross-fertilisation
that occurs
when you put a bunch
of curious programmers
together. In a similar
vein, we have no sponsors
and nor do we allow sponsorship
at the conference or any events
because we believe the community
led effort works best when
there's no outside influence.
We're also focused on
diversity and have
goals on providing travel grants
to those who need assistance
in attending the meetings.
So why am I here today?
Well, I hope you're you'll
understand that the R/pharma is
a very open organization made
up of volunteers we'd welcome
anyone wishing to get
involved, from presenting at
a meeting to reaching out to
the community with a question.
And more on how you can
get involved in 2021
a little later.
But first, I'd like to
share some information
on how we've evolved since 2018.
R/pharma holds a
conference each year.
The first was held
in 2018 at Harvard.
And if you're unable to attend,
many of the presentations
are available on the
R/pharma website,
the link is on this slide, and
I invite you to peruse them.
We had around 150
attendees, which
was limited by the
size of the venue,
and it ran over two days.
We're lucky to have some
really amazing keynotes
that are listed here.
There are a number of
amazing general presentations
that ranged from RNA sequencing
to how to convert statisticians
to data scientists, to
using R energy analysis to benefit the environment.
One thing was
clear from 2018 was
that Shiny was the main focus
of most presenters' work.
In 2019, we repeated to the
conference, this time expanding
to longer workshops
each half a day.
Once again, the
conference was held
at Harvard, the
mixture of keynotes
and general presentations
for around 150 attendees.
I'd really like to highlight
the workshops here.
So we've reached out to a
number of workshop presenters,
all of whom agreed to
put together a half day
workshop at no cost.
And all the workshop materials
and many of the presentations
are available through
the R/pharmar website.
What was interested in 2019
was still a focus on Shiny,
but there was a huge
focus on reproducibility.
So like many other
groups in 2020, early on,
we decided to switch to a
fully virtual conference.
This provided few benefits over
historical in-person meeting.
First, we could
reach more attendees
and we received over
500 registrations
from 26 countries.
We're expecting around
300 and initially, it
prepared for up to 500,
but as soon as they opened,
it was clear that we were
going to hit 1,000 plus.
And the graph on the right is
actually really interesting.
It shows the registration.
This was registration
without advertising.
So just through word of mouth,
it's amazing how quickly
we had registration.
Secondly, we could
attract more presenters
because people didn't
have to travel.
There were more people
willing to present.
And in fact, we had over 200
proposals for presentations.
Conference was held over three
days each, each four hours long
running in the morning for those
on the West Coast of the US
and the evenings in Europe.
So I also want to highlight
the workshops that
were held for the 2020
conference because
of the virtual nature, we
could organize a little bit
differently, stretched
out over multiple days.
We ran a total of 11
workshops through the week
before the conference,
each 3 to 4 hours
long with some
incredible presenters who
put a lot of time and
effort into building them.
And all the environments
were pre-configured
under RStudio Cloud.
So it was very easy
for people to come in
and use the materials and
access them afterwards.
Once again, these were all put
on by the presenters, no charge
and once again, the
conferences is free anyway.
So it was a really
amazing piece of work.
R/pharma meeting for
2021 is almost certainly
going to be a fully
virtual event.
And thinking about the trends
we've seen over the past three
years R is definitely
growing within the pharma
and biotech industries.
Why the rate?
We now have more mature
infrastructures in place
and there's definitely a move
towards more submissions using R.
In addition,
there's greater work
in combining languages such
as R and Python, R and SASS.
I want to switch gears
just a little bit
and talk about something new.
We'll be launching a
learning and development
platform this year called
learn r in pharma dot com.
And the goal of this is to help
former professionals develop
the skills needed in the
drug development space.
The R pharma group will be
helping community members put
on workshops, lectures, teaching
labs and Cloud environments
with the aim of building
practical R skills
in a friendly environment.
At a very high level,
what we're hoping to do
is to put together a
monthly write up on a topic
and then follow it by a lecture
or workshop or even a workflow,
maybe a community discussion.
This is one way that you,
the pharma community,
can contribute.
You'd like to lead a
discussion group, teach a lab,
please get in touch with us.
Contact details will
be on the final slide
and keep an eye out for learn
r in pharma dot com. We'll announce more
through our Twitter feed and
the R/pharma website.
The first R/pharma a conference
that we held three years ago
was dominated by
Shiny apps. We can
see how Shiny can play a role
in modernizing the submission
process, but it's
fraught with challenges.
These can be related
to technology,
regulatory agencies, training
and validation, qualification,
and even people and
culture, plus others.
In 2021, R/pharma
wants to tackle Shiny
for submissions as part of
learn r in pharma dot com.
R/pharma is all about
the community helping
the community. This
year, we're looking
to launch learn r in pharma
dot com, which I spoke about.
So if you have an
idea for a write
up, followed by a lecture,
workshop, discussion,
please reach out through the
website, email, or Twitter,
and we can help you
find like minded people,
provide logistics.
Some examples might be combining
R and Python or building a
validation framework.
Shiny for submissions
will be part of this, too.
Finally, a huge thank you to all
of the presenters and workshop
hosts over the past
three years, putting
So much effort, along
with the advisory groups
and Harvard who have
supported the conferences
that we've held, and I thank
you for your attention.